did there come a time when your brother
and miss heard started to live together
yes
and when did that occur approximately if
you recall i don't recall the timing i
don't recall the time frame i
believe
they had moved downtown
um
to the eastern columbia building
but i don't remember exactly when that
was
uh what type of structure was the
eastern columbia building was that a
freestanding house or was it apartments
it's apartments and he had
he had the
penthouses on the top floor how many
penthouses did your brother own on the
top floor of the eastern columbia
building i think it was five apartments
do you know who lived in those five
apartments when your brother and miss
heard went to live there i know who
lived down there i know isaac a friend
of johnny's name isaac lived down there
i know
amber's friend rocky and her boyfriend
lived in one of the penthouses
amber's sister whitney
lived in one of the penthouses when you
say rocky are you referring to rocky
pennington yes
and was her boyfriend josh drew joshua
did rocky pennington and josh drew
pay any rent to your brother
no what about miss heard's sister
whitney did she pay any rent to your
brother no do you know why your brother
allowed them to live rent free at the
ecb because they were
they were
do you know why so if she knows she can
answer allow it all over
she was his personal manager that's fine
did you arrange for
handling a lot of your brother's uh
bills i would give them to the business
manager um
but i
i i believe
they were amber's family and friends
that's why he let them live there
how often did you see your brother when
he was living with miss heard at the ecb
penthouses we didn't see him as often i
didn't see him as often
he pretty much stayed down there he
didn't come back you know towards where
we were in west hollywood
very often unless he had a reason to
and on those occasions when you did see
your brother what observations did you
make he was always in a hurry when he
was able to come back he you know he
could never sit and spend
the time you know he
it felt like he was always trying to you
know get back uh downtown
he he
he just seemed so much sadder he did not
seem himself he was
he was always
his
his person was much
just sadder in that time period when
your brother and miss heard were living
at the ecb did you have occasion to
observe them together on occasion would
you please describe for the jury what
you observed on those occasions when you
saw your brother and misheard together
different occasions i've seen them
together
when they've come into the office i mean
in your capacity as johnny's personal
manager do you know whether your brother
and amber ever tried uh ever travel
together
yes they did travel together
there were
i mean there were times when you know
when johnny had to go do press or
film
they traveled together what type of
travel arrangements did you make for the
two of them when they traveled together
we would get a
a
private plane
that took them to
whatever the destination was
um
and make sure that we had you know the
hotel accommodations
uh taken care of
part of
part of what we did was to always make
sure that we anticipated you know
everything so we would do the uh
the travel the hotels uh cars drivers um
i would i would make sure that there was
an extra hotel room
you know for trips when they would go
why did you make sure there was an extra
hotel room when
johnny and miss heard
went on trips together because their
objection to the extent the answer all
right i don't believe it does okay
that's fine
you can answer ma'am oh thank you i
booked the extra hotel rooms um
because if johnny was at home or you
know anywhere like that he was able to
if they argued he was able to
leave the room leave the argument and go
like he's always done and hide
in a different room to get away from it
when when they were traveling for
you know the different reasons for press
or whatever
and we booked the hotel rooms
i wanted to make sure that there was an
extra room
you know
because
it wasn't unusual didn't mean for them
to have an argument so i wanted to make
sure that there was an extra room did
your brother ever have occasion to use
that extra room that you booked for him
yes objection foundation all right a
sustainable foundation if you want to
lay a foundation i think the foundation
was she made all of the travel well i
can actually lay it through some other
questions as well she was
person personal manager
um
whose idea
was it to book
an extra room for your brother when he
traveled it was my idea because you know
um i saw a repeat happening in life when
we were
when we were kids and and
arguments and fighting would start to
happen our first thing was to go and
hide and
you know get away from it and
[Music]
since i recognized
what felt to be
a a pattern that was a repeat pattern
from his childhood
i've
i wanted to make sure that there was a
place that he could do just that
did you book your brother's hotel
accommodations during the 14 years
that he when he was with vanessa parody
yes
did you ever book an extra room when he
was with her objection
no
overall allow that one go ahead
if you could repeat it i don't think the
jury heard that i'm sorry
no i did not
did you ever hear
your brother
and miss heard argue
objection
no
did you ever
see or hear any physical altercation
between your brother
and miss hurt no
what can you tell us about what you did
observe
of your brother and misheard
together when i saw them to me he was
always trying to make sure he was always
trying to make her happy he always made
effort to to sort of make her happy
she's a very strong personality and my
brother's personality came off much more
soft at that point to me did you observe
any occasions in which miss heard was
nice to your brother i've seen her be
nice and and you know
you know offering to you know
bring him a drink or you know get him
whatever i mean just a typical like a
typical nice i've seen that have you
witnessed any occasions on which
ms heard wasn't nice to your brother i i
have would you please describe those to
the jury yeah this one really stayed
with me on
one occasion we were i was at the office
and i'd had a meeting with dior who had
wanted to sit with johnny and talk about
you know working together and amber had
come in and asked if she was
interrupting us and uh we said no and we
weren't supposed to really talk about
the meeting with anyone but johnny told
amber that i had just had a meeting with
dior and that you know they were
interested
in
him
um
her
her reaction
to that was
she was in disbelief and sort of
discussed um because she said dior why
why would dior want to do business with
you they're about class and they're
about style and you don't have style you
know so it was a insulting kind of
taking away that one moment you know
that insult is there i've seen the
insults multiple times actually what if
anything did you hear ms heard say about
mr duff's physical appearance she called
him an old fat man how did he respond i
believe he's heard her call him that
himself